richard moran is author of executioners
current Thomas Edison George
Westinghouse banned the invention of the
electric chair it's the story behind the
struggle for control of New York's
electric market in the late 19th century
this history on book TV feature runs
about 50 minutes thanks it's a great
pleasure to introduce my friend Richard
Moran who's known to many of you in this
room lots of people even if you don't
know him by face you may know his voice
as a commentator for some years on
National Public Radio's morning edition
you may also know him as a contributor
to the op-ed pages of most of the
country's major newspapers including the
New York Times the LA Times The Boston
Globe and the Washington Post since we
have a larger audience today I'll
continue to play resume for a moment and
tell people who don't know that he has
been a professor of sociology here at
Mount Holyoke College for 125 years
that's what he told me I think that's
right he's the author of knowing right
from wrong the insanity defense of
Daniel McNaughton and of the brand new
book he'll be discussing tonight
executioners current Thomas Edison
George Westinghouse and the invention of
the electric chair it's a pleasure to
introduce Richard not least because he
has loyally attended readings by my
husband and me at the Odyssey over the
years richard has been a loyal friend in
more ways than one
he Anton his wife Danielle even offered
me the use of the electrified gazebo on
the beautiful grounds of their house to
write in that gazebo was surely the
inspiration for my husband's gift to me
of a writing gazebo some years later
though this one was not electrified I
hope by now that you have noticed my
clever and offhand use of the word
electrified Richard Moran's new book
executioner's current is a history not
only of the electric chairs invention
and implementation but of its
justification or some people's attempts
whether well-meaning or self serving at
its justification what I like very much
about Richard Moran's new book is what I
like about Richard and perhaps the best
way to talk about that is to remind us
in case anybody's forgotten that this is
election day
I've never asked Richard to tell me his
party affiliation but what whatever it
is nominally he is always at heart and
independent you cannot predict what he
will say or even if on an off chance you
can predict what side he's on you won't
be able to predict why he hasn't a way
of introducing a single historical fact
or a conjunction of seemingly unrelated
statistics into a conversation and
completely shifting its focus you
realize that you were out of focus but
Richards manner is so genial that you
feel Jen genuinely glad to be corrected
a few remarks about executioners current
it is like Richard Moran unclassifiable
it begins with an execution the first by
electric chair in the United States and
ends with the trial that led up to it
but somehow the suspense is even keener
after you know what will happen it's a
history of science and yet we come away
with a vivid understanding of certain
misunderstandings about electricity by
the great Edison himself it's a history
of patents marketing public relations
and just plain lying
it is a courtroom thriller and a
historical novel that happens to be true
it's an avocation of the past that never
condescends to the past or makes
previous generations quainter or more
wiser or our own wiser finally it is in
its last pages a political and
philosophical argument for
self-reflection how humane are we human
beings really in splitting hairs over
which form of capital punishment is more
humane are we missing the point but as
I've said before Richard Moran is an
independent so I will let him make the
point himself
please welcome Mount Holyoke professor
of sociology and my good friend Richard
Moran
but that really was a lovely
introduction but it's gonna be hard to
fall as you all know I wrote this book
about the electric chair and I thought
what I would do tonight is a little bit
what I've done in the introduction to
the book which is to tell you how and
why I got interested in the electric
chair
now my first encounter with the electric
chair actually occurred when I was a
small boy growing up and eat the shadow
of the bridge that separates Boston from
its northern suburbs on a hot summer
afternoon my mother took my brother and
me down to Bellingham Square to see a
full scale model of the electric chair
as well as a replica of the prison cells
I don't really remember whether the
state of Massachusetts so the city of
Chelsea Randy exhibit but I shall never
forget the grim lesson of crime and
punishment that it was designed to teach
if you did something bad you did
something wrong then they would get you
in the end my mother was always afraid
that something would happen to us she
was afraid of accident she was afraid
that would be be the victims of crime
and she was also afraid that she would
lose us to the streets she always said
that little criminals grew up did
committed little crimes and big
criminals grew up from little criminals
to commit big crimes and yet you don't
start out on death row it's something
you have to work on getting to well that
night my brother and I both had
nightmares
I remember being strapped into the chair
naturally I was innocent of the crime
that had brought me to this dreadful
moment but somehow the evidence against
me was both strong and incontrovertible
I woke up in a cold sweat just as the
execution of pulled a switch as I
struggled to gain my bearings my brother
burst out of his nightmare and we just
kind of looked at each other for a
little while
rolled over and went back to sleep to
this day I can't really shake the
feeling of being strapped into the chair
and being condemned to die for crime
that the real me didn't commit although
my brother seems to have forgotten the
incident entirely my second encounter
with the electric chair came almost
twenty years later when I was a graduate
student at Northeastern University my
professor the late Stephen Schaffer
asked me to take over a class and bring
them to a tour of Walpole which was the
maximum security prison the state of
Massachusetts near the end of the tour
the God took us to death row which had
been abandoned for more than 25 years
over in the corner was the old electric
chair the one used to execute among
others the Italian anarchist Nicola
Sacco and pathology bands Eddie in the
1920s to mice to my surprise the guard
asked me if I wanted to sit down well I
was kind of maybe 22 or 24 years old and
I was leading the group of students were
only a few years younger so put on the
spot and not wanting to appear too
cowardly I sat down and I first of
course looked over at the switchboard to
make sure that it really hadn't been
used in 25 years but I sat there and
contemplated what it might be like to be
executed on the way out the guard said
to me that in all the years he had been
running this tour I was the only one who
had ever taken him up on his offer so I
kind of liked a joke that I'm the last
man to sit in the electric chair in
Massachusetts and really the only one to
have to get out now my third encounter
with the electric chair was the occasion
for the my book here
although the route it took was somewhat
indirect for some time I had been
interested in the social transformation
of the death penalty how our idea
is about the nature of punishment had
changed over the years and I began my
inquiry with the observation that new
methods of execution developed during
periods of mounting opposition to the
penalty of death opponents tend to use
the gory details of a botched execution
to rally opposition to capital
punishment consequently it has been the
proponents of capital punishment those
who want to retain capital punishment
who have led the effort to find more
humane methods of execution this was
true for the scaffold the guillotine the
electric chair the gas chamber and the
hypodermic needle the purpose of course
has always been to make executions more
palatable to the public with this in
mind I began an investigation of lethal
injection the newest and the most humane
method of execution after thinking about
how to capture the essence of a modern
execution I decided that I needed to
witness firsthand an execution by lethal
injection I had a colleague in Texas
with the University of Texas at
Huntsville is only about a hundred yards
away from death row and he was able to
arrange for me to witness an execution I
have written about that in the
introduction briefly and I'll just say
that although much of the gore has been
taken out of the execution process much
of the Hara still remains now a few
weeks after I returned from Texas a
colleague of mine in Boston asked me if
I might lecture on the application of
new medical technologies to the science
of killing he knew that I had witnessed
elect an execution and he by lethal
injection and he thought that I might be
able to bring some special insight to
the problem of cow
little punishment to prepare myself I
began researching the history of lethal
injection and much to my surprise I
found that the idea of putting condemned
criminals to death with the liesl lethal
dose of drugs had been around at least
since the time of Socrates and that the
hypodermic needle itself invented in
1832 and used heavily in the Civil War
was not indeed a high-tech instrument
but a very low-tech one in other words
it turned out that it that lethal
injection was not a hi-tech death but a
low-tech death proposed and rejected
many centuries ago also I looked at a
report written in 1888 by the state of
New York in which they looked at the
most humane ways to execute condemned
criminals and they concluded that the
electric chair would be the best but
that second was lethal injection and had
it not been for the influence of Thomas
Edison and others we would have had
lethal injection over a hundred years
ago anyway the important thing I
stumbled on in this report was the story
of the bitter struggle between Thomas
Edison and George Westinghouse for
control of the emerging electrical power
industry what sometimes called the
Battle of the currents and how this led
to the invention of the electric chair
what follows is that story in 1882
Thomas Edison began the age of
electricity by illuminating the
commercial and financial districts of
New York City near his Pearl Street
generating station in fact he
illuminated Wall Street JP Morgan's
offices and the offices of the New York
Times
four years later in 1886 judge
Westinghouse the inventor of the air
brake illuminated Buffalo New York
Edison lighted New York City with direct
current or DC and Westinghouse employed
alternating current or AC and it's this
simple distinction that holds the key to
understanding the invention or the
origin of the electric chair now almost
immediately after AC was developed it
became recognized as superior
unlike DC which required thick copper
wires and frequent power stations AC
could be transmitted over great
distances for relatively low cost
as a result Edison began to lose market
share and many of his agents deserted to
Westinghouse with sales sagging and
Edison being threatened in the industry
that he single-handedly created he
decided to attack alternating current as
dangerous contending that the high
voltage necessary to transmit
alternating current had caused several
accidental deaths by attempting to
associate alternating current with
danger and death Edison hoped to
overcome the inherent economic
disadvantage of his competitors product
but Edison of course couldn't do this
all by himself
so enter Harold Brown Harold Brown is
probably if you have to suggest who
invented the electric chair I guess it
would have to answer Harold Brown he was
a self-taught engineer who in June 1888
wrote a letter to the New York Evening
Post outlining the dangers of
alternating current claiming that in
just a few years more than 60 people had
accidentally been killed by alternating
current in his letter Brown accused the
alternating current manufacturers of
which which mess
Westinghouse was prominent of placing
their own financial interest ahead of
the wealthier of the public that may
found sound familiar to some people
supporters of alternating current fought
back contending that Brown was
uneducated and unqualified to make such
a determination George Westinghouse
himself asserted that alternating
current was actually safer than direct
current since it entered households at a
lower voltage to prove himself correct
Brown approached Thomas Edison at
Edison's West Orange laboratory Brown
conducted experiments that demonstrated
that less than 300 volts of alternating
current would kill a dog while the same
dog could survive a thousand volts of
direct current soon after Brown
initiated a public campaign to ban
alternating current of more than three
hundred volts now anything more than
three hundred under three hundred volts
alternating current had no real
advantage of a direct current but since
you could push it along Y as in lines at
three thousand volts that's where its
advantage was you could send it over
long distances and then just bump it
down for how so low residential use you
couldn't do that with direct current
with direct current it came out at a
hundred volts and it went as far as it
could till the resistance caught up with
it and as far as it could be utilized so
before an audience of professional
electricians and journalists at Columbia
College's School of Mines Brown
electrocuted a 76 pound no foolin dog
named - afterwards he proclaimed that
alternating current was suitable only
for the dog pound the slaughterhouse or
the state prison meanwhile New York
State had formed a commission to inquire
into the best method of executing
condemned criminals
several prediction particularly gruesome
hangings had convinced death penalty
advocates that a more reliable and less
painful method of executing criminals
was needed if the public was to continue
to support capital punishment they had
several difficulties if you try to hang
a person and you have a long drop and if
you drop his body too long you'll tear
his head right off causing a very
gruesome execution if you don't drop
them long enough you won't break this
neck and then he'll strangle to death
and that could take 30 or 35 minutes to
happen indeed friends and relatives
would often jump on the feet of a person
who was being hanged in order to hasten
his death so Thomas Edison getting back
to the story here at Thomas Edison's
appearance before the Commission proved
pivotal the legendary inventor convinced
commissioners that death by electricity
was quick and painless provided of
course that alternating current was used
ironically given the present debate over
the methods of execution death by lethal
injection might have been the first
choice of the Commission had it not been
for the opposition of the medical
profession now passage of the electric
execution law on June 4th 1888 New York
legalized death by electricity the
medical legal society was charged with
the responsibility of working out the
details
somehow they decided to engage the
services of Harold Brown the only man
who seemed to know anything about
executing animals after further
experiments on animals at the Edison
laboratories Brown recommended 300 volts
of alternating current for fifteen to
thirty seconds the Commission accepted
his recommendation although it did ask
the doctor Judge fel of Buffalo to
redesign the chair alternating current
would soon be
as the execution is current Braun and
Edinson had achieved their goal George
Westinghouse was not happy let me tell
you he attacked the scientific validity
of Browns killing experiments and he
pointed out that Braun was employed by
Thomas Edison to scare the public into
thinking that AC was too dangerous for
residential or business use Brown
responded by publicly challenging
Westinghouse to a duel at the old
fashioned old time but a new kind of
duel in a New York Times advertisement
Brown proposed that each man be hooked
up to his respective electrical currents
and that the voltage be turned up until
one of them cried out that they had
enough needless to say judge
Westinghouse declined the invitation
despite this mean-spirited controversy
surrounding Brown the superintendent's
of prisons of New York authorized him to
supply and install the electrocution
apparatus as you might imagine
Westinghouse would not sell him his
powerful alternating current generators
but Brown remained determined to
associate the Westinghouse name with
death by electricity once again with
Edison working behind the scenes Brown
was able to get the Thomas Houston
company which was in secret negotiations
with the Edison Company to later form
General Electric to go through a used
Dynamo dealer in Boston to come up with
the three alternating generators that he
would need on the very day that these
generators arrived off in prison William
Kemmler I quote a brute who chopped a
woman to bits with an axe was sentenced
to death by electrocution who was Kembla
well Kemmler William Kemmler
was born in 1860
he was one of eleven children of German
Lutheran parents who lived outside of
Philadelphia in a place called
Germantown on the night of his honeymoon
he discovered that his wife was already
married he therefore got got himself in
a kind of a tizzy and he didn't know
what to do so he then met Tilly Ziegler
who was the sister of his brother's wife
who herself was married he there and he
ran off with her to the City of Buffalo
and cam was set up a small he was a
fluke huckster he was a fruit peddler he
was a huckster II peddled fruit for a
living and one morning while he was
getting the chickens and the horses
ready his wife came down and asked him
or his paramour came down and asked him
for a bunch of eggs he brought those
eggs up and something happened something
ensued and he chopped her to bits with
the hand hatching the interesting thing
about this is that their little daughter
Ella who was just four years old
witnessed the whole thing
and Kembla took her to the next-door
neighbor and mrs. Reid and he said here
take Ella he said I have killed her and
I'll take the Rope for it and then he
left to go to the local bar room where
he drank until the policeman came and
got him now Kemmler basically was
arrested in charged with first-degree
murder he pleaded alcoholic insanity as
a way of really trying to bump his
murder charge from first-degree to
second-degree murder so that he would be
able to escape the death penalty he
argued that he was his
brain was so destroyed by alcohol that
he was unable to premeditate a crime and
he argued that unsuccessfully as one
might imagine and he was sentenced to
death and since the law had just been
passed
he was the first band ever sentenced to
death under the new law now lawyers for
Westinghouse were not happy with this
and they were determined to stop this
execution and Westinghouse hired a kind
of dream team of attorneys and paid gave
them or Allah gave them a retainer of
$100,000 to support Kemmler in his
appeals now Westinghouse's attorneys
then appealed to new york state
contending that electrocution was cruel
and unusual punishment prohibited by the
state constitution a hearing is was held
in which edison while contending to be
against capital punishment assured the
court that death by alternating current
was quick and painless upon examination
both Edison and Braun own boldly denied
that their support of electrocution by
alternating current had anything to do
with their financial interest in direct
current Kemble a--'s motion of course
was denied as was a similar petition to
the US Supreme Court
okay the execution on August 6th 1890
William Campbell became the first person
to die in the electric chair
when Kamla entered the death chamber at
6:30 a.m. he was calm he instructed the
guards not to hurry and he told the
warden to take your time and do it right
later he asked that the electrodes
attached to his head be tightened for
the sake of the 27 assembled witnesses
all men of science and law a leather
mask was placed over his head temblor
was a relatively simple man who believed
in science and he did he believed that
his death would be quick and painless
and that the doctors would see to that
at 6:40 a.m. William Kemmler received
two applications of 1,300 volts of
alternating current the first lasted for
only 17 seconds because a new
unstretched leather belt belt was about
to fall off one of the second-hand
generators the second jolt lasted until
the smell of burning flesh filled the
room about four minutes as soon as his
charred body stopped smoldering Kamla
was pronounced dead Edison must have
bribed an editor because a headline in
the morning paper read Kemmler
Westinghouse
now although the execution itself was
terribly botched New York prison
officials claimed proclaimed it a huge
success a triumph of science and
humanity over barbarism and brutality
but critics took a different take on it
the electrical review summarizing
editorials in the popular press declared
that CEM lers death would almost
certainly mark the end of electrical
executions the New York Times
however cautioned that it was much too
early to pass judgement and that this
was only the first experiment judge
Westinghouse called it a brutal affair
and said that he hoped the public would
lay the blame where it belongs squarely
on the shoulders of Thomas Edison Thomas
Edison for his part defended the
electrocution he said that the
electrical current should have been
applied to the hands because that was
how most accidental deaths by
alternating current had occurred he
assured critics that the next time death
would be quick and painless in fact the
end of the book we talked about I talked
about an execution in which they
actually do it the seventh execution is
done the Edison way and that turned out
to be worse really than the prior six
months actually okay now what does the
Kembla story mean why is it important
why would anybody want to study it other
than it's a damn good story well it does
have implications for science and
technology and how science and
technology often influences social
policy the electrical execution Act of
1888 is itself the founding document of
modern execution protocol temblors
electrocution is generally regarded as
the first modern execution
it is the first it was the first to
rationalize the process of putting a
person to death by employing science and
technology in service to humanity and it
was the first time that the press was
legally barred from attending an
execution and publishing its gruesome
details once stripped of its symbolic
content and instructive purpose the goal
of an execution was merely to kill the
condemned as quickly painlessly
inefficiently
as possible thus the electric chair
embodied the most power two of the most
powerful cultural components of late
19th century America a fearless almost
fanatical faith in progress and a
growing adherence to inflicting physical
pain on fellow human beings now the
Kemmler execution also has legal
significance for one the courts still
rely on camlet today for the proposition
that all methods from shooting to
hanging to lethal injection are
permissible under the Eighth Amendment
of the US Constitution as long as it has
a humanitarian purpose or effect but the
most significant and legally sound
contribution of enrage Kemmler to the
eighth American America Eighth Amendment
jurisprudence was the standard of
Cruelty it proposed a standard that will
be recited or recited repeatedly
throughout the next century punishments
are cruel when they involve torture or
lingering death when there is something
inhumane and barbarous something more
than the mere extinguishment of life now
the question that really impelled the
writing of this book
is the following can any method of
execution ever be considered a humane
for at its core this is really what the
debate on capital punishment is all
about and that if you look at even the
last ten years of Supreme Court
decisions they seem to be trying to pick
apart the most egregious elements of the
death penalty
whether it be racial discrimination
proportionality mentally defective
[ __ ] defendants and I was quite
surprised to see that they refused to
see to hear the the recent case on
whether juveniles could be executed for
crimes that they commit while it while
juveniles anyway it seems to me that
what has happened then is that this
question is the one that remains it's
the one that we need to face the one
that we need to ask ourselves can an
execution ever be considered humane take
questions
anybody have any questions
Richard I have two questions for you one
concerns the I guess ethics of
witnessing and execution as a death
penalty opponent I wonder where they
share with us your sense of whether as a
death penalty opponent it was an
ethically appropriate thing to do to
witness the execution and the second
concerns the way you ended with the
concept of a humane execution um would
you say that capital punishment could be
accepted if a humane execution a humane
methodology was created or creatable or
would you say that ultimately the
question of capital punishment doesn't
depend upon the question of technology
no I would say that that I think at the
very end of the book that which which
you read because you gave me a very nice
blurb in the back the last question you
know is how do you end this book and the
question that I dealt with was do you
end it with the question
look I ended this talk can there be
anything such as a humane execution or
can we only hope to have a quick
painless and maybe certain execution and
if that's all we could hope for is that
a humane execution without giving away
the legate's with giving away the last
side of the book I say that we need to
face up to the fact that there is no way
to have a humane execution that's not
something that can be done and we need
to face up to that and the rest of this
is just a distraction trying to achieve
something that can't be achieved but the
SEC first question is one that I have
never been asked I have never even
thought about and I've never been self
challenged that that somehow am I going
down there was unethical
well I'd like to say about this book
that that this book is not for or
against the death penalty as much as it
is about the death penalty and what I
felt when I went was I wanted to
understand firsthand what this execution
ceremony was all about I needed to do
that if I was going to write about it
and quite frankly I never thought about
whether it was ethical or not quite
frankly I don't know what do you think I
think you need to think more about it
well while I'm thinking maybe it'll be
another question just sort of on that
topic um have you ever known somebody
who has a faced execution and if so what
was that experience like have I ever
known anybody the answer the shoddy
answer that is no the longer more
complicated answer is that I have cars'
ponded with the last ban in Ohio who is
going to face executions by the electric
chair and he wanted to use the electric
chair because he didn't want this idea
of lethal injection the idea that his
death would be a simple falling asleep
passing away so I corresponded with him
for a while September 12th was when he
was supposed to be electrocuted that did
not happen
I did talk to him for maybe thirty
minutes on the phone but that's really
the closest I've come to talking with
somebody beforehand the execution I did
see in Texas I did not meet mr. barefoot
beforehand the first time I saw him he
was already a
the gurney already prepped so no doesn't
grow out of that kind of personal
experience what percentage the United
States now what are the people on death
row what are they facing which two forms
of execution almost everybody's facing a
lethal injection what has happened is
that in 1967 when the mandatory 'm the
de facto moratorium on executions took
place and all the states had to rewrite
their execution laws as those new laws
were rewritten many of the states became
concerned that the old methods of
execution might be vulnerable to a
Supreme Court challenge so they started
switching over from electric trous
electricity to lethal injection many of
those states did it with the combination
like if you committed your crime before
the state then you had the electric
chair afterwards for legal reasons
because they thought there could be a
challenge to changing the method so most
of the people I would say Austin
probably give me a bet give you a better
answer than I can but I would say most
of them are facing lethal injection
movements throughout new forms of
execution that Europe no I don't think
so I haven't Dez been suggestions you
know but I don't think there's a
movement I think that the proponents of
lethal and of capital punishment are
pretty happy with lethal injection I
think what it does for them is it it's
the only method of execution that
there's any ambiguity in can allow you
to have the kind of a sleep metaphor
that the person goes off to sleep we're
putting him to sleep it's wrapped in
medical technology and it can even get
in the idea that it's for the person's
own good as for the as for the good of
society so I think that they're very
happy with lethal on Jack
the image that it has the reality that
it has it to set its mug it's as often
botched as an electrocution but that
isn't the public image J and on what
happens to people who administer
electrocutions and who are part of the
paid staff as opposed to the political
partisans of capital punishment well you
know there has been there has been some
studies on their their effect I don't
think that you know they yet the
old-time executioner the 17 18th 19th
century used to be a public figure and
everyone knew him today of course the
executioner's are hidden from public
view and very often they don't know
their own identities
most states however are going to a kind
of a team of executioner's that are
selected among volunteers from the
prison staff and it's kind of seen as
almost an elite group and I don't know
if there's many studies that show what
the effects on on them are certainly
we've had wardens and stuff that you
know have administered 3540 executions
and then said that they've had enough
but I'm not sure that it's all that
devastating on them to tell you the
truth so the whole system is designed to
deny responsibility so that nobody
executes say nobody killed Thomas Andy
barefoot nobody did in fact when the
prosecutors will say he killed himself
by committing his crime the jurors will
say he killed himself by committing his
crime the clerk state will say that
everybody says it and the execution team
will tell him it's not personal
we're just doing our job so nobody kills
him but himself I guess
Richard I was wondering if you had an
idea of the electric share outside of
the United States and how it was applied
elsewhere outside of this edison Weston
the mainly American uniquely American as
is the gas chamber and as is
lethal-injection uniquely American yeah
most Europeans don't understand the even
then they didn't understand America's
use of capital punishment
certainly not the electric chair Texas
is you know another world and what is
interesting is that capital punishment
actually causes us a lot of problems in
the international community especially
in the human rights area because every
time I negotiate is sit down to talk
about human rights somebody throws up
you have capital punishment the state
that your president is from say and they
keep throwing that in our faces and a
few of the people that I have talked to
in this on these negotiating teams just
wish we get rid of it for no other
reason then you know it's a kind of pain
and they keep throwing it up in our
faces
yeah but I would say one thing all the
European countries who got rid of
capital punishment did so in the face of
public support for capital punishment
and it was only five ten years later
that the population came around and now
I'll say people in England and France
they in Germany they look upon the fact
that they don't have the death penalty
as being superior to us Americans when
indeed it was their politicians that
abolished the death penalty against
their will our politicians respond to
the people
is is that in part because maybe they
did continue the death penalty with
methods that were not seen as scientific
would that maybe be part of the well I
know the Brits always liked the hanging
the rope they thought that was somehow
superior and they also were interested
in lethal injection in 1954 but they
said it was an undignified way to die
and so they've always had this strange
affinity for the rope but nobody
considered the Chad now now nobody loved
progress the way we did but Americans
didn't seem to come around to opposing
the death penalty during the interval
when the death penalty was not was not
allowed why do you think that is oh why
not like the Europeans well it wasn't a
ban on the death penalty it was a kind
of ban on the way that the death penalty
was administered
that's a good question why didn't we
then after having stopped it and bleed
most of the opponents of capital
punishment believed that if we could
just stop it for 10 years it would be
very difficult to get started again
no and the first execution indeed was a
volunteer Gary Gilmore so so the first
executions were mostly white volunteers
and it got the whole execution system
moving again but yeah you're right I
don't know why I guess because it was
during a high-crime period that's
another thing that's when this thing
happened but I think it's because we're
more democratic maybe our politicians
respond better to the people or our
leaders of followers is probably like I
don't know
buddy also have a question well let me
read just a little something here what I
think has happened that might that might
stuff shine some light on some of these
issues
okay in surveying the entire history of
capital punishment it's most obvious
that every so-called advance and the
means of execution has been in response
to a rise in the opposition of the death
penalty the shift from public to private
executions from hanging to electrocution
from the chair to the hospital gurney
each hat represented an attempt to
defang death penalty opponents by making
the process appear more humane and yet
the unspoken truth is that the humanity
we are protect protecting is our own
humankind's Nash natural revulsion at
the prospect of taking even the most
evil life by sanitizing the process with
advances in science and medicine with
the idea of progress we have managed to
turn a public ceremony designed to
venerate the power of the law in the
primacy of the soul into a private
procedure that happens offstage as part
of a consoling ritual known as justice
it is for this reason that methods
calculate - calculated to meet the cruel
and unusual standard so often end in
appalling savagery and why the legacy of
the electric chair is not quick and
painless but the very opposite William
temblors hideously botched execution
arose not from simply scientific
incompetence of business deal as dealing
but from the erected soluble divisions
of our own soul perhaps our objections
to killing another human being could be
overcome if we had a clear
on the deserv'd nature of punishment but
we are a society distrustful of courts
and other public institutions suspicious
of our own values and deeply committed
to the belief and the sovereignty
sovereignty of the individual excuse me
in order to impose the ultimate penalty
we need to place full responsibility on
the individual for his behavior the
concept of full responsibility however
is better fitted to an earlier age we
know too much about the workings of the
human mind the vagaries of human nature
the political economic and cultural
components to which crime and punishment
is intricately related our understanding
of unlawful behavior no longer rests
solely on a nineteenth-century free well
view of human motivation if it did
executions would still be public and
justice would not have to be served in
private the story of the invention of
electric chair reveals how science
technology in progress first became
linked in the application of capital
punishment the involvement of Thomas
Edison and others dramatically
illustrates how a moral issue of
humanness was transformed into a
technological problem of quick and
painless and eventually into a legal
question of cruel and unusual and that
is a kind of typical thing that will
happen we will transform moral questions
into arenas either technological arenas
or legal arenas so that we're better
able to deal with them and as I said the
end we may find a quick and reliable
method of execution but we need to face
up to the fact that there can never be
anything an execution can never be
considered humane thank you
richard moran is author of
executioners current Thomas Edison
George Westinghouse and the invention of
the electric chair it's published by
Knopf a division of Random House visit
Random House dot-com / Knopf for more
information
next week history on book TV features
Michael